[Music]
what's up you guys here's another
episode of you welcome with me Marcel
Arguello you got a great one today we
have my guest
Laurie Kilmartin the incredible writer
on Conan and my former mentor that's so
great lady come on I quit I couldn't
handle it
she'll be at the punchline in San
Francisco October 16 through 19 and we
also have the incredible nicole Thurman
great comedic actress you may have seen
on a black lady sketch show and shrill
on Hulu thank you ladies for being here
so much appreciate you coming out Amy
how are you me
yeah I'm fine it's one of my favorite
things about this show is like all the
one we got like you feel a little spiffy
yeah I wash my hair I love it I know I
also washed my hair warning there are
some Dave Chappelle's sticks and stones
Netflix special spoilers so if you don't
want to be upset which you probably do
too don't watch this part ok I want to
talk about the scrutiny of comedy that's
happening right now Dave Chappelle
special was I mean I found it very funny
the effect of opinion I have about it is
like the offensive jokes were like not
creative yeah right so that's that's
where I'm at with it
I assume you girls walk you ladies
watched the special your thoughts on his
special I really liked it and I I I felt
like it to me read mostly of satire it
didn't read much as offensive it was one
of those things where I didn't notice it
until it came for me you know I mean
like I was like I don't know if it's
that offense but I think it's okay I
think you could see the audience for
being a little like but you know when he
said that like 36 year old there's no
such thing as 36 year old good [ __ ] I
was like okay yeah until he makes fun of
you yeah it's like then I don't want to
be that person I want to be like we're
empathetic but I was kind of
like I don't know like I felt like he
she was treading on dangerous territory
but I felt like he always kind of
recovered it and didn't ever go to too
hateful or to too dark I don't know I
guess I wasn't reading it that way you
know he's he's planting think pieces I
do think it's interesting that that
comics I feel aren't used to being
critically looked at you know and if you
miss musicians have had this sort of
attention from critics when they drop an
album or special for like 40 years and
you know Rolling Stone and spin and
cream like there's whole full magazines
do you know devoted to critiquing music
and I think comics have just gone under
the radar for so long and you know
through up through like the 90s no one
paid attention to stand up at all in
terms of critiquing it and I think
people aren't used to it yeah they're
used to getting away with a lot of
really bad material or happy stuff so
not necessarily Chapelle but when other
comics see Chappelle bean critique you
like oh my god if he's being critiqued I
have 40 minutes that suck that's
hilarious I didn't think about that I
didn't realize that no one was
critiquing stand-up back to be a comedy
is trolling I mean that's what she'll is
doing yeah yeah yelling a lot of people
and he's loving it cuz he's doing with
the smile on his face and I think that
that's part of what makes this kind of
funny is that we've taken trolling to
the next level if we've got yeah you
know I've got the government involved in
getting these w2's okay it paid to troll
the Guardian recently reported that
there has been a study that the happiest
and healthiest population subgroup are
unmarried women with no children is that
true no because I'm both you're also
married with no kids and they battle how
is your experience I'll tell you what if
mixed it's not a no it's like I guess I
don't choose to be unmarried with no
kids it just kind of happened I tried to
be not great at relationships I have to
be horrible at picking relationships
yeah so it's kind of happened but I
don't know sometimes I wish I had a
partner
never sure if I wish I had kids I'm not
sure yet I think I need a partner to
know if I want to have kids sure that's
just how I work and I feel like day to
day I know that I I kind of call I kind
of joke about it with people a lot like
I live the treat yo'self lifestyle right
like if I'm having a bad day I will like
go shopping all right we'll go get treat
you know like I was like literally will
do something for myself sometimes I
really enjoy that freedom that it gives
me yeah I mean for me it's the freedom
to use my vibrator as I please yeah one
of the perks so yeah keep a vibrator in
your home
absolutely Laura might you not I have my
buried Laurier shall have a 13 year old
how old is 13 almost 13 but you're
unmarried marry so now this is a mix I
know I've half of what you guys have
yeah I can't I it's possible to get in a
terrible relationship for a while have
the child and then get out right that's
what I did do you recommend that Lauri
yeah I can't recommend almost anything
I've ever just like the way you guys
move you unmarried childless women if
there's like a lightness to you that's
true they don't understand anymore I
recognized it on my former self
and it's weird like I remember before I
had a kid I'd you'd see something like a
new story of like someone's kid got
killed and it's like oh that's too bad
click don't care moving on immediately
and now I'm like how could happen to me
and then I'm like spiraling for an hour
and how do i how do I prevent that from
happening to my son and I'll never not
be like that for the rest of my life
I'll always have that wait how old are
you when you have 41 okay right so
you've got to do a really wonderful life
better you don't remember were you
living in New York I went oh so it was
like well you were really getting
[ __ ] and suck and like crazy like
crazy yeah so when I was 19 my brother
he had his his first child he was like
six months my nephew at the time was six
months and my brother had a drinking
problem so he passed out on the couch
while I was like playing with his son
yeah and we were the only ones home so I
was like playing with the kid and I'm
just like oh I need to take a [ __ ] so
I'm gonna go take this baby in return it
but I didn't know my brother was passed
out and so I was like 19 years old
holding my six month old nephew on my
lap like you know rocketed while I took
a [ __ ] and it really just has stayed
with me when I think about even the
desire to have kids I'm five and I'm
having a baby fever and it's been like a
journey dealing with those emotions you
know I met my friend's baby and I
started crying and I was like not yeah a
thing that I do I've ever done I have
eight nieces nephews I've never cried
when I met them I was [ __ ] weird as
[ __ ] yeah yeah so it's tough I mean it's
it's wild and I think I definitely think
that there's pros and cons to both but I
definitely feel like you only know the
pros and cons when you're single and
childless I think it's my hardest but I
think it's really hard to see the price
well maybe for me it's hard to see the
pros when you're childless though like I
don't cuz cuz as a person that doesn't
have kids I don't I'll never don't know
what that connection is to a child but I
don't understand them who are like when
you have Kendall in your Stannah like it
they spit in your face you'll be like oh
my god that's my child like you know
you're like that I'm like no like that's
disgusting - - but I don't let my son's
right parents have this kind of
connection that we don't feel at all so
I think there's like we don't we can't
really know what it's like to have a kid
I don't know we will never really know
unless we have one also with our career
it's always like it's so up and down
that just when you you're gonna be fine
you know I don't have a kid now then
you'd like something happen yeah yeah
cancel there like whatever happened guy
leaves you or a guy leaves you and then
you're like no I have to spend all the
money on my dang self and that's
expensive you know just to be by
yourself I go back and forth and I think
sometimes I'm like I just wanna have a
kid to have somebody to take care of me
when I'm old right it's very selfish
reasons and I want to see what a kid
would look like that I have
like that's like what I think I think
more people should be comfortable dying
alone in their bed like beautiful image
I'm just like bummed I don't have
someone to take my day out on ripped
into us oh I would love that that's real
that's so [ __ ] real because it's like
for me it's like therapy AMF is one day
a week that knuckler um friends you know
we live in Los Angeles friends are cool
but like they're not always there
they're usually doing their own yeah I'm
worried about their own lives and a lot
of your friends will end up with
partners around our age you know with
our 36 year old like you know truly like
they end up with they end up with
partners and you don't have anybody to
come to and come home and talk to you
and that feels like that's what that's
why I feel like I want a partner first
that's all I'm that's all i worried it's
not all I worry about with that what I
worry about more than a kid because it
feels like you need someone to hop you
need a team you know Tina you need
someone to be able to [ __ ] to or
someone to be able to like talk [ __ ] on
like everybody with you like they'll
they're there with you it's also good to
be able to talk to a partner about the
kid and like if you're in a situation
where you guys don't talk or it's bad
then you're making all these unilateral
decisions and it's it would be nice to
have the input of somebody there was
this great thread on Twitter somebody
started about the row and how you know
everyone thinks the rows like this man
had just lived alone dramatically and
and really thought about himself and it
turns out his mother was doing
everything for him doing his laundry
coming out giving him sandwiches she
owned the land that Walden Pond was on
so it isn't the mythology we think of
it's not true right so you guys are
artists and you know you need we all
need somebody to help us like right
you're gonna be the mother then you're
racing the Thoreau instead of being the
Thoreau in some cases I always think
about Beyonce because her father was
that for her and that's the thing that I
don't think he gets enough credit for
because where she's at right now is
because her dad took so much on his
shoulders and I think that's the other
flip of a lot of successful women that
even though we want to give them all
credit there's so much to building
successful person period which is what
your point is but I guess what I'm
trying to say is if you can handle me
come get me
[Music]
we are now at the Q & A portion of you
welcome if you want to submit any
questions about life love pursuit of
happiness etc etc submit them to you
welcome questions at gmail.com alright
ladies are ready for these questions
yeah okay the first question do you ever
get performance anxiety or stage fright
even sometimes just going out with your
friends or literally going up on stage
what do you do to combat that anxiety I
mean yes I can you all do I don't think
no one doesn't not get anxiety or stage
fright but it just kind of depends on
the scenario right yeah I mean for me I
get it all the time
I get it going out with my friends I get
it in auditions I get it doing shows I
get it doing something like this you
have to like be on at any time I'm very
like if you want to leave you can go the
thing is for me personally it's about
self doubt and like self judgment and so
that's where it comes from and it's
something that I'm working on like
really hard because I feel like the more
I doubt myself and the more I'm judging
myself in any particular situation the
worse my performance will be right what
it is date on a hang with friends like
whatever it is so I've been really
trying to work on that and I quit I used
to drink like I don't drink you hour and
I used to drink like even if I was going
on stage like doing an improv set or
something I'd have like you know a
little bit of whiskey like you have
something to warm it up and same with
like hanging out with friends you know
one glass of wine cools you off then you
can go out but like now I don't drink so
it's been a really interesting
progression to like learn how to deal
with performance anxiety in every
situation I've gotten a lot better about
it what about you Laurie 20 years of
stand-up I feel like they should start
drinking that might soften oh and some
times before like I said I'll think am I
really about to stand up on there on
that stage and I would look at the
audience and I'm like I don't like these
people I don't know these people why to
be relatable and I parties like what if
I just ran away like what would there be
any repercussions or would it just be
like consider one
I'm crazy thing or could they get away
with it I mean I've never had it's like
unwanted thoughts and rumors I think
I've never done up that I was I think
about it sometimes when my dad passed
away we had a funeral and there was
supposed to be no speeches and then
somehow whoever it was in charge just
like to somebody want to give a speech
and then my mom was like yeah but it
also has to be in English I can't just
be in Spanish and then she went back to
me and I was like oh my god I forgave a
do like impromptu speech and I'm like
the best speaker in Spanish I can speak
Spanish but like not in that kind of way
and so that was so that was like the
most anxiety I've ever had
and yet it worked I got laughs in both
languages and I keep thinking every time
I get worried or I start feeling anxiety
I'm like it's still not as bad as my
dad's funeral speech like there's
another thing that tops that yeah I
guess I feel I mean to combat it want
you to combat the anxiety is like you
just kind of have to face it head-on
right absolutely that's the only way or
stop drinking you know deal with it well
so do you ever stop drinking but also
like realize what the source of it is
not listening to that [ __ ] that your
brain is trying
yeah the strength to take control the
narrative yeah I'm not to overthink and
yeah that's like what you said because
it's like you have the worst show of
your life it's not gonna be that bad
it's like it's always everything in
comparison is gonna be easy so yeah you
just don't have to yeah you think about
like put it in perspective and I ask to
think the more you get used to it like
you just go oh that thing's popping up
again think about taking control the
anxiety is like just being like oh
that's part of what happens like I get
sweaty okay I get sweaty that's what I
need them I'm like I'm sweating because
I'm nervous ladies night it was a very
important question we have here where do
you stand on the washing rinsing of
chicken before cooking issue these like
Twitter things I've gotten no but I mean
it sounds good to me I am NOT a cook
hey you don't cook okay so you have no
idea no I like okay I think it's like a
black Twitter thing we're black it is a
box oh yeah why people nasty yeah I mean
it's like
don't fall I don't watch chicken before
I yeah you shouldn't know yours put it
doesn't it kills it does like it gets
trims on your counter and yeah yeah oh
yeah right that's like it's like a whole
thing of you're supposed to watch the
inna the counter or if you wash the area
yeah I wash my legs I just want to you
watch your leg thank you Laurie
where's that news to you that people
weren't washing their legs I can see how
you think though it's rinsing down right
and it and also I swim a lot so I do
feel like I get pretty fried in the pool
but yeah I do
I can see how it happens nice to mix up
for the white I may have done it but but
no it's a renewed vigor now to wash my
leg oh great yeah our legs are feeling
and smelling good you guys can touch
after this okay I really want to do it
on campus so we all don't know yeah
don't wash it or where's the chicken
even the phrase to be washing your
chicken just sounds disgusting yeah
sounds nasty you're something baby
Spiegel matter on the chicken oh you
wanted so but it doesn't matter because
the heat is what kills any bacteria it
could still be there I mean it's dead
fecal matter but you are is that team is
that they think about like shrimps you
as chef has this little poop thing think
about when you eat boo yeah I don't eat
with the shrimp in the booty with that
your answers have been answered your
answers have been questioned man your
answers up in question there it is thank
you ladies for coming on to you welcome
and please follow these very funny
ladies on Twitter to my favorite
accounts to follow Lori with the classic
joke I mean this [ __ ] can read it joke
has some wild perspective and hilarious
videos that I really enjoy and
how you guys you welcome [ __ ]
this is a great episode tune in next
time
[Music]